at light of life we've been impacted by
the opioid epidemic so we have people
who are coming to use our services
because they're homeless because of
their addiction as well as people who
support the mission that love someone
who has an addiction to opioid addiction
and they don't know what else to do and
so we thought putting together this
documentary and it's comprehensive and
showing a lot of different angles of
addiction from people who are actively
using people in recovery and the people
who have lost someone to an addiction so
in the spring of 2017 I was walking
through Market Square and I saw somebody
pass out right in front of me
and I knew that it was drug-induced
based on the crew that this person was
with and living downtown and seeing
homeless and addicts all the time it was
I don't my reaction was shock I would
talk to the team here but we were
talking about what they were doing for
outreach and they had just started their
outreach team at light of life and we
were given permission to follow them
through the encampments all through
downtown so that's how I have the
needles started as we were filming last
fall we were actually going out into
homeless camps you know walking into a
homeless camp there's a lot of sensory
things going on you know and you're
seeing tents where people are living and
you're smelling the smells that go with
people who have lived outside for a long
period of time and it was really
powerful and they were really kind and
welcoming to us and we wanted to be able
to give people who don't have that
chance to go out the same experience to
say like wow this is where someone lives
this is what it could be like for
somebody who's living under a bridge or
you know out in the woods and so the art
installation gives that opportunity
there are tents that are recreated to be
just like some of the homeless camps
that we went in I think it's really hard
for people to understand what
homelessness is like and what addiction
is like you can show them something on a
video but if you're able
to give them something that they can
interact with and engage with and we
wanted to make sure that people
understood this this is what life is
like one misstep can lead you into this
and and with addiction especially opioid
addiction it can be anybody there it
knows no race it knows no gender and it
knows no age it doesn't care where you
come from it will get you everyone is a
person and a human being sometimes it
can be easy to talk about them you know
those people that are using but there
are people too and they have people that
love them very much I think it's so
important to remember the dignity of the
person and that that when you see
somebody struggling like that that
there's a story and there's a family and
there's a history behind them I think so
quickly we come up with preconceived
ideas of why that person is there and
why somebody is living that life and you
couldn't be any further from the truth